I've not had anything to eat since
breakfast
I've got no money to get any food or get
any drink
really hit me now how bad things are
really are
I've got 20p
to my name
that's it
Danielle and her two children Brooke and
bryony have struggled through this
entire year life's Essentials like gas
electric and food now so expensive they
often go without
there is no heating my fire is the only
source of heat
I feel like we've gone back in time
every day it's just another fight it's
just
what are they going to eat today how am
I going to keep the house warm
how am I going to get into school how am
I gonna you know just
it's just
trying to get through one day at a time
and it's a struggle
I know who I get that from
he
according to the Joseph Roundtree
Foundation as the year nears its end 4.3
million low-income households have
fallen behind on their bills and are
going without an essential like food
warm clothing or even prescriptions and
three million low-income households
haven't been able to heat their homes
and that's before the predicted cold
weather next week
the average low-income family is in
arrears of over 1 600 pounds with 2.4
million now relying on credit to pay
their bills
I've got a six pound 63 emergency
remaining and I owe seven pound eighteen
the month's just
and then gas wise that's outside and I
hate I haven't even looked at it
recently because I didn't yeah you all
70 quid yep
so you're in debt to the gas and you're
in debt to the electricity yeah and I
haven't even got anything emergency wise
on the gas so your gas is off at the
moment yeah you've got no gas no gas
because I can't afford to repay that
right now
at night I struggled to get to sleep
because I think what if this time next
year I'm not in this place what if I'm
in a completely different place or I'm
in a homeless shelter or I'm out on the
streets or something
like other households Danielle's
received government support to help pay
for her electric but she's still
struggling this is where I spend all of
my evening my little heater goes on
before bed
and as soon as I get up in the morning
to try and make it more bearable it's my
safe place but it's also my worst place
everything hits me when I gets her in
bed
so it is it's my sanctuary and my dark
place
I don't know how I'm gonna face
Christmas if I'm completely honest I
think it is going to be the case of
little little things that cost nothing
but
it's all I can do I can't plan for
tomorrow I just gotta just deal with it
when it comes
Danielle is now falling behind on the
rent
she's coming to terms with a stark
reality she no longer has enough money
to live on Nick Martin Sky News
leicestershire